he is very sophisticated for a guy who
comes off maybe as a little
old-fashioned he's very sophisticated
about the way the media works in our
country and appeals to I'll say again
tens of millions of progresses who don't
want this election to be a bad ideas and
drama but to be about progressive ideas
you mark I think you're right he's got a
couple other attributes which make him a
bit more of a threat than one ordinarily
be the case i think americans love
authenticity and they think there's not
a lot of it in politics today and Bernie
Sanders like him or not is authentic
that was vintage Bernie today and
secondly something that I think
transcends ideology there is a populist
streak you see it some in the Republican
Party some of the right-wing some of the
Tea Party movement an anti Wall Street I
don't think there's a great climber of
support for billionaires in America
today so he's tapping into something
that made it could conceivably enable
him to slightly broaden that rather
narrow based on the left that he enjoys
how just talk about him as a performer
again he always died bristles a little
bit when John and I try to talk to him
about his family as I said in his
personality but it wasn't a very happy
warrior out there today does he have a
chance to broaden his appeal if he if he
does talk a little bit more
optimistically about what he'd like to
do rather than denouncing corporations
denouncing the wealthy well if he makes
a scary face like he does to you and
Johnny petrified John last time maybe
baby maybe that I don't think humor is
going to be Bernie's trademark he's an
enjoyable guided to chat with I think he
actually has his case said earlier a
decent relationship with his colleague
he occasionally has turned into a decent
legislature he and John McCain put
together the veterans of foreign package
a year or so ago but I don't think that
Bernie is going to be the Hubert
Humphrey of 2016 he's really not a happy
warrior he's going to be much more of a
scolding lawyer ya cain't hunter back on
Capitol Hill what did you see today in
Bernie Sanders a big day for him first
time ever as an announced presidential
candidate is what everybody else saw
what you see every day up there
was there anything different about how
he was behaving given his new status in
the world well I think you saw a classic
Bernie Sanders I mean this is what we
hear from him you know on Capitol Hill
every day in terms of his you know
devotion to certain issues one of the
things that struck me is that he talked
about you know wanting to have basically
a competition of ideas to talk about you
know being in the race to sort of both
see if it's possible for someone who
isn't going to take money from
billionaires and from you know
corporations to be able to mount a
viable can't see almost like as if it's
an experiment to see if this will really
work and also to kind of bring his sort
of ideas to the table and the the
policies that he wants to see and I
think that's been very similar to the
role that he's taken on in the Senate
over his time both in the Senate and in
the house okay do you think people like
the senator from Massachusetts the
senator from Ohio chard Brown do you
think any of Bernie Sanders colleagues
at a vidya logical solidary the more
liberal ones will endorse him well
that'll be one of the most interesting
things to watch actually as he was
walking away after the press conference
myself and several other people though
rather short press conference myself
inside that several other people went up
to him and one of the questions we asked
was whether he was going to keep his
democratic part or I'm sorry is
independent party affiliation in the
Senate now he's running as a Democrat
for the presidency and he didn't answer
that or answer any of the other
questions but it'll be interesting to
see whether his Democratic colleagues
who now caucus with whether any of those
that you mentioned Elizabeth Warren
sherrod Brown folks like that Matt
whether they come out to endorse him now
I'm not familiar with all the current
ballot rules but I remember from past
campaigns it seems to me in some states
he might have to be a Democrat to be
enough to be the nominee of that state
in to win delegates right yeah mark I'm
not familiar either but I go ahead I'm
sorry Kate were you I'm sorry cave Kate
Kate mania may know more about that than
I do I think that's a technicality
that's pretty easy to bridge there's not
you know there's no there's no vote for
another nine
I think that's not hard to do right Kate
just a closing thought from you in terms
of Bernie Sanders we've seen with the
three Republican senators who are
announced candidates for their party's
nomination a real tension in the case of
senator Cruz for instance missing a fair
number of votes trying to balance the
Senate platform in their day job with
running for president would you expect
Bernie Sanders now to continue to be up
on Capitol Hill alatar is your
understanding her since that he'll be
focused more on trying to win the
nomination than doing the duties the
people Vermont's that him to Washington
to do well certainly in the next week or
two he's gonna be very involved in
getting final passage of the budget
resolution that he's a pretty strong
opponent of it's a Republican crafted
budget resolution so he'll be pretty
involved in that but he's also planning
a more formal campaign announcement up
in Vermont I think in May and so
certainly will be seeing him he's been
traveling a bit over the last several
months on two primary States to sort of
get ready for today but I would imagine
we'd see that ramp up in the next couple
weeks as he you know it's the trail more
more ardently I'll share your curiosity
is with the world what are the next two
or three things you're looking to see
happen now that Sanders is an announce
candidate that you think will tell the
tale of how influential he is in the
nomination fight two things mark hal hal
senator Secretary Clinton responds over
the next month and how seriously she
appears to take it secondly where we'll
burn ego I think he'll be out there as
Kate said well will it will the focus be
heavily on New Hampshire where I think
he could be a real sleeper candidate not
to win but again a Buchanan analogy a
lot of independence will vote in that
Republican primary they tend to be more
moderate which leaves the Democratic
vote and that primary a little bit more
to the left will he do that or we also
try to compete heavily in Iowa too he
may he could spread himself too thin ya
li just had a third thing to that which
I'm curious to see how he does in that
online fundraising that he said to small
dollars and he said would be so
important we'll see how he does would be
with the publicity of the announcement
and again I'll say the third time tens
of millions of Americans will find this
an appealing message we'll see if they
get on board the Sanders train